This course is more than just lessons. There's problem sets, a final
project, and a whole community of other people just like you taking
this course. You'll find the problem sets at the end of each
lesson. The purpose of these is to give you a chance to
practice the skills that you learned in the previous lesson. After you
finish all the lessons, you're going to create a final project, which is
an app of your choosing that you're going to build, with all those
things that you've learned. Finally, there's
the community. If you ever get stuck,
or just want to chat about your incredible app
ideas, you can go to the discussion forum.